The Fast and Furious movies have never
been exactly realistic but some fans are
racing to criticize this plot hole in
fast X could it have been avoided nobody
likes a guy that points out plot holes
where you're walking out to the theater
more often than not pointing out these
moments either betrays a
misunderstanding of some aspect of the
story or an unwillingness to engage with
the film on anything other than a
literal level however there are some
rare instances in which plot holes do
genuinely undermine the ability to enjoy
a film story such is the case in fast X
the fast Saga has never been known for
its airtight logic in fact they're
seemingly aware of how absurd these
movies have become and are flaunting it
as a marketing strategy that said
there's one aspect of the film's
internal logic that simply doesn't make
sense in the world of Fast and Furious
throughout the film one of the
storylines the audience follows is Jacob
toretto's quest to get Little Brian to
safety the parameters of the mission are
vague even by fast and furious standards
though things got even more confusing
when a character reveals that Brian
O'Connor the former franchise co-lead
played by the late Paul Walker is
somehow entirely safe from harm with his
own family what makes a story Choice
frustrating is that such an imaginative
solution to an obvious problem that
creates more questions than it answers
while it's understandable why FastTech
would want to address his character in
some way simply not mentioning him at
all would arguably be preferable to this
if it was a matter of involving their
late co-star in the story somehow they
were surely more meaningful ways to do
so if it was a matter of filling the
potential plot hole of why Dante Reyes
wouldn't go after Brian's family the
film is underestimating its audience the
characters seemed so positive that
Brian's family is safe that they don't
even question or worry about it for more
than two lines which both makes for a
fleeting tribute and immediately raises
a question of why Dom's family doesn't
join him at this supposed impenetrable
safehouse obviously there's a real life
reason for Brian's absence from the
story Paul Walker died in a car accident
on November 2013 in the midst of filming
Furious 7 leading Walker's real-life
Brothers to step in along with some CGI
help and complete the unfinished scenes
Furious 7 ultimately ends with a
touching pseudo acknowledgment of Walker
death that's Brian and Dom drive down
two separate roads while See You Again
The Wiz Khalifa and Charlie puth song
written as a tribute to Walker plays in
the background while it was a meaningful
send-off to the character this led to
some awkward moments as the films have
continued when discussing how to stop a
seemingly evil Dom in fate of the
Furious the idea of bringing back Brian
to help is immediately shot down by
Letty Brian would know what to do no
we can't bring Brian a man to this when
dumb sister Mia appears in a larger role
than F9 Brian's absence becomes even
more notable if his wife is returning to
the fast family then it strains the
audience's suspension of disbelief that
Brian wouldn't be along for the ride
Ryan does seemingly arrive at the
barbecue that ends her film when his
trademark blue Nissan though audiences
don't actually see him step out of the
car as the series has continued on
without Walker it's become increasingly
clear that there's no interest from the
filmmakers to recast Brian or use a
digital doppelganger to allow the
character to return to the series in a
larger capacity that leaves a series in
an awkward place as darm and the rest of
the family need to acknowledge that the
Brian character still exists without
actually bringing him back into the
story in the case of fast X maybe it
would have been better for that
acknowledgment to have never come up
especially since Dante doesn't seem to
have any trouble finding any of the
other characters that he's seeking
revenge against